[Music]
the
issue with chappelle and his recent
thing is called redemption i believe yes
right
my issue with chappelle is chappelle is
the living goat
in my opinion he is the living greatest
comic
alive yeah the greatest comic ever is
patrice o'neill
but alive i think that's a chappelle to
be honest say what i think i'd say
chapel oh okay that's fair enough
that's just i can handle yours yeah
exactly at this point like the top
five or ten are interchangeable amongst
personal opinions yes right
but most people agree on like the topic
he's one of the greats and nobody's
disputing that nobody's just being
unbelievable a talent yeah unbelievably
brilliant
brilliant how he orchestrated this to
get
his show back brilliant was brilliant
brilliant negotiation
we spoke about i think last time he made
the show valueless
yeah and when a show is valueless the
owner
of course will give it away because he
can't get anything for the show
not only was the show valueless it was
so toxic and radioactive
that by still owning it as comedy
central it made comedy central look bad
[ __ ] brilliant it was a genius
strategy to get the rights of his show
back
that is not the issue i want dave
chappelle to have the money
more than i want comedy central to have
absolutely common central sucks
absolutely always talk i want dave as a
comic
to have the money and have the rights
for his show that's not a question
i'm just disappointed by
how he sounds in this that's my issue
it's like
it it seems to me and don't get me wrong
being the most famous comic in the world
is probably hard and being looked at as
a god
amongst people is probably hard and
it just feels as if like he doesn't have
people in his camp
that are willing to go hey bro
i don't know if you should put that
thing out where you call yourself a hero
five times like that's not a
comic thing to do like usually we make
fun of people who call themselves
heroes right like a hero's like being
heroes like having a nickname like you
can't give yourself
the nickname like people decide if
you're a hero
and people decide your nickname right so
i feel like a little disappointed or sad
because i'm like
bro this is this is not what we do as
comics and
it seems as if there's no personal
accountability whatsoever
for like what happened here right i want
him to have all the money
i want him to own the [ __ ] show over
comedy central shore
but let's be honest about what happened
you signed
the contract that you wanted because you
the ball was in your court you got the
biggest [ __ ] contract ever
everything that you wanted you got right
you walked away they paid you money you
did not pay the money back
right yep they held the rights to the
show that they
owned per your contract
and you're upset at them in no way
is there no personal accountability at
all
yeah man i don't again brilliant
negotiation he used his leverage
his leverage it's of genius negotiation
but the mischaracterization of how
everything happened
and even when he's talking about getting
coveted early on
he i had to perform well i can't not do
live shows till 2022
that's why i got covered because i was
performing you're also there's pictures
of you
at bars with no mask there are stories
of you getting into fights with people
masculine at a bar right don't make it
just hey i'm a hero
who has to perform for everybody i love
my craft so much that's why i got cold
be three-dimensional in your story yeah
i was i kind of didn't give a [ __ ] and i
got kovac that's what it was
fine i did shows because i loved
performing don't give a [ __ ] went to
bars cause i was tired i miss people
whatever i can handle that yeah yeah
little [ __ ] like that and again i
brought it up last time but it reminded
me of the um
i used to not smoke and drink and tell
this business no
no i was a good muslim before whatever
religion you are
if you start smoking and drinking you
[ __ ] up you failed your god
that's not anybody else's fault yeah uh
peer pressure
yeah were you [ __ ] 12 years old
you're 30 years old you're a [ __ ]
multi-millionaire
and these execs are going to get you to
smoke and drink your pressures away
go to a [ __ ] therapist bro yeah yeah
like just
go to a mosque talk to your mom your
best therapist yeah yeah yeah
i just don't like that aspect of him
terrorists not terror
i just don't like that aspect of what
he's doing again i think he's the
greatest comic ever i think he's
[ __ ] brilliant a strategy to get his
[ __ ]
strategy to get his show back i'm
riveted whenever he speaks and to your
point
but someone in the crew need to step in
and be like bro like you called yourself
a hero five times i didn't even
catch that so this is all that's all i'm
saying i'm watching it and i'm going
imagine he said that and then had to sit
next to patrice
after the show oh at the back table to
sell it 100
patrice would tear his skeleton from his
body
he would literally tear his skeleton out
of his flesh accountability king
accountability king to a fault very much
there is a patrice documentary i think
on comedy central and that's the reason
why no one has [ __ ] seen it probably
but this is the greatest ever please go
watch it
find it it was produced by all things
comedy great guys over there that's bill
burr's company
and go [ __ ] check this killing is
easy is that the one say it again
killing is easy
there's one that's supposed to i thought
it's supposed to still come out cold oh
maybe it hasn't come out yet
we will find a way we'll put some links
in there but dude i'm telling you this
is the greatest
point is like if patrice was around
there's no way chappelle walks off stage
and patrice doesn't go
hammer him like he'd be like bro it was
a sketch show not the declaration of
independence relax
that's not heroic you there are people
like fighting in wars
there are different things here not
fighting crime yeah
like come on they're like frontline
workers
even if you are dealing with all the
people that get corona
from courtney
or from your general reckless behavior
we all got covet i got covert at a show
right i'm not a hero i didn't do it
because i love performing i wanted to
perform selfishly i got colbin
never once did i talk to you guys like
hey man you know i just love the game
i just had to give the people that want
to get in now granted much much smaller
audience
but i just had to give my fans with no i
got called because i've made a decision
yes i i live with the consequences and i
remember charlemagne saying about kanye
knockout home
kill almost killed half the comics in
new york that's really important i did
this
i gave colin quinn colvin
not because i'm a hero because i'm
[ __ ] up yeah i miscalculated selfish
i'm selfish frankly i'm selfish yeah 100
i needed to perform bro nah you're a
hero bro yeah
yeah yeah that's right we never thought
about that you know i thought you're a
[ __ ] hero
for doing corona and getting the netflix
special shut down
thank god i got some hey
it's because i'm heroic i'm a front line
worker said i'm a front line would you
do all this heroism
and not like get a show back or
something like oh don't move
bro give farmers their rights
if you're gonna be so heroic and perform
stand-up comedy so that people can tell
you how great you are on a nightly basis
it's definitely just for the people it's
not it's not for you at all you know
unreal yeah unreal and
it's not like you're building houses for
the homeless that's selfless
but going on stage and telling jokes so
people say how amazing you are
that's selfish we do that for us it
makes us feel really good
mutants will benefit if you guys laugh a
hundred percent but we're not going to
be out here going this is only for y'all
i'm only performing and i'm a chappelle
fan like i know we all are goat yeah
i've
i just wish someone in the crew would be
like bruh this is what i'm saying
charlemagne said this about kanye i
think in his book in black privilege he
says like nobody
in his crew told him no and that was a
massive problem they always
gassed every id head somebody that's the
same similar thing right now somebody in
chappelle's camp
needs to check him a little bit be like
bruh you might be the greatest ever
you're doing too much with this i'm a
hero [ __ ] and if you drink and smoke
that's not their fault
that's your fault that's personal
accountability take that you are
masculine bars take that that's
it that's the only reason why it's
disappointing you want the people that
you admire and the people you look up to
and the people you've looked up to
for years you want them to be personally
accountable
for their failures and i hope that i can
be
personally accountable i know i have
guys that are on my team that will tell
me
when i'm [ __ ] up almost to a fault
the second i talk about anything alex
immediately comes up to me you know what
i mean is it alex would be like bro
you were wearing two expensive shoes on
a podcast people gonna think you changed
yeah i bet all right like after this
podcasting bag i think we should cut the
part about the watch people are going to
think you change
just kind of think of that dirt al is
wearing a whole rolex on his
arm that he owns i'm wearing my girl's
rolex
and he's still like bro you changed okay
you're wearing your girlfriend's jewelry
your [ __ ] change and when you switch
this podcast back to a gold flavored
tuna it's so funny you posted something
to your story
and i was like that's a little racist
and i like hit him up about it i'm like
i don't know about that one he's like
what you said what'd you say
so i posted uh tim dillon posted a video
of uh i think it's his opener a guy
named dan i think his name is
and uh of dan like throwing water
outside while it's freezing cold you
know sometimes the water will change to
ice in mid-air whatever because they're
in texas and it's freezing you know
[Laughter]
and uh and i go i respond to the video i
go uh wow
tim is making so much money on patreon
on here as a white maid
right and al goes that's a little racist
and i said blame forrest gump because
remember the movie for his gun
that's right the whole point about
bubba's family
was they had white white maids literally
the joke was
they started out as a maid she started
as a mate and then
yeah she mentioned so rich people were
working for her that she had a white
mate
so i learned it from forrest gump who's
a great guy so you can't blame me i
really learned it from bubba
and bubba's mom who got a white maid as
soon as she could dude oh yeah she's
putting that made through the wringer
josh whedon got
nothing on his mom she is running that
[ __ ] through the mud oh my god
anyway so um i guess in conclusion
awesome that chappelle got the rights to
his show great great
yeah i mean it's great that he built up
enough [ __ ] power that he could
force them to do what he wanted yeah uh
but disappointing that there's not any
personal accountability at all
for like how it went down yeah and i'm
starting to notice the tides turning
even within the comics that i talked to
yeah before we all were kind of like
everything chappelle does is great
and then i was a little bit unsure about
one or two things but i they would
100 stand and now they're all just like
what the [ __ ] is he doing that's the
other thing we're the only comics
probably they're going to talk about
this publicly yeah
um i don't think any other comments
would go on podcast and talk about it
uh every comic that i've spoken to
it's not even close every comic that
i've spoken to every single one
every single one feels this exact same
way
yeah if not stronger
that's all i'll say i mean he went from
do what i'm saying is that that's it and
i don't blame them for not saying it
because a lot of these guys
would love to get the opportunity to
like open you know or be a part of that
world which is awesome don't get me
wrong it'd be amazing to perform with
chappelle
i just feel the exactly he's the
greatest comedic mind in history
genius his mind born like the way it is
blessed to do comedy i'm patricia
the way his brain works i marvel at the
[ __ ] unbelievable
his call back the uh he saved what he
raped i legit
got up unbelievable like i watched
lebron hit a game-winner against the
magic same reaction
holy [ __ ] i can't believe what i just
saw when he wants to get busy
there is nothing like and that's what
makes this sad
i mean like i asked my non-comic friends
about this i was like what is your
reaction like i
i'll ask industry people like what they
think about it because i'm curious i'm
like i want to make sure it's not just
me that has this kind of like
cringe-worthy reaction
and it's the same dude and i understand
you get to a certain level of
of success where people aren't going to
tell you that
and i'm sure that on a much smaller
level
much smaller level i would experience
that
not from you guys but from people maybe
outside of our circle
right maybe they wouldn't want to say
that i'm doing something stupid or maybe
i want to say that i'm you know being
sanctimonious or something like that but
what i hope that we keep an energy here
is that we're going to be honest with
one another and say hey listen you're
crossing the [ __ ] line or hey you're
doing something that
maybe you don't want to do and then it's
up to me
for you to make that decision to
continue that yeah like if we say that
to you
like i mean we've all had like horror
combos off podcasts just about like
personal [ __ ] yeah and we have these
[ __ ] and we go through it and
sometimes it's tough
yep it's tough but you got to keep that
yeah
you know and yeah i don't know i just
yeah i think because we love him that's
why we're disappointed in this that's
why the emotion is like stronger like
bro
if you put out a special right now that
was like comedy it'd be so
[ __ ] good yeah be so [ __ ] good or
even just if you want to be a
storyteller and talk great
but just don't call yourself a hero and
say you got covered because you're a
hero
and you know whatever the [ __ ] else just
stop mischaracterizing how things happen
be honest with yourself and someone in
his camp you can't expect fans to do it
yeah someone in his camp got to be like
bruh
you're the you're the greatest quite
possibly goat
this is [ __ ] you got to chill on some
of this that's it
that's why you need patrice man that's
why you need [ __ ] patrice
i know patrice was that [ __ ]
dude anybody
yeah patrice was that [ __ ] who'd
be like man cut that [ __ ] out
no he would go beyond cut that [ __ ] out
yeah yeah he he what he'd do is he'd get
up from the table
as chappelle was walking over but let me
make some room for the hero
everybody he makes some room for the
hero
you know me i love heroes eating them
sitting next to him i
love me some heroes as any frontline
workers here you should thank this man
for the sacrifice he made to get his
show back in business yeah
he's working overtime
oh man but for real though thank you for
you know being out there and doing shows
because we got some shows coming up
you can go check out theandresults.com
for all of our upcoming dates
backgasting.com over here that's right
akashing.com we're back on tour
it's called the heroes tour the hero
yo you should call it big hero seeks
hey bro i'm one [ __ ] away you're one
[ __ ] away dude
you